let's revisit your talking about before
the break yeah
because we got to get to power rankings
right we got time
i want three divisions again i want east
central and west and
you're gonna here's the problem you're
gonna have six teams in one division but
you know what it was good enough
back between 1999 and 2001 when the
browns were put back in the league
before the texans arrived and they
reconfigured when they were 31 teams
the nfc afc
central had six teams right so
you're gonna have six five and five or
five six and five however you figured
out geographically and let's tear down
the walls let's make it truly geographic
east central west the way that it should
be and it's never been eaten
just to your point too and when we were
when i was growing up in the 80s
the nfc there was a 28 teams so the nfc
east had
five teams i believe the nfc central had
five teams and then the nfc west had
four teams
which used to piss me off because i used
to go man the 49ers got
one less division opponent and they all
stink and here's the giants and my dad
playing the eagles cowboys and redskins
and the cardinals were the throwaway
game
and before you were born the seahawks
and the buccaneers weren't in the league
when i discovered the nfl it was 26
teams
so it was the east in each conference
that had
five and the central and the west had
four i'm saying
five five and six in each conference and
and look i don't know who's gonna get
the short straw and have the 16 but the
bottom line is this
you got three division winners and if
you're the best of five or six
teams it dilutes the possibility that
you're going to get a quartet
of crap teams like we seem to have every
year this isn't
a once every 50 years
phenomenon finally got there phenomenon
this is every year and for two straight
years now it's the nfc east and all you
have to be is assigned
to this crap conference jerry jones
called it yesterday manna from heaven
that they're in the nfc east where
they're in first place with a two and
four record it's embarrassing to the
league
to have a division that's that bad yeah
let's have three divisions
and you know here's the other thing too
you have built-in expansion slots if
they ever want to get to 36
because the ultimate end result would be
6 team divisions the division champions
get in
and if you have 36 teams you got five
wild cards after that we don't have
enough good players to fill out 32 teams
we don't need four more
i think we do i think we do i think
there's enough quarterbacks now to make
it happen
maybe there are maybe yeah i mean i i
don't disagree i i don't know if i'm i'm
gonna buy and i understand what you're
saying as far as
the three conference thing definitely
would limit
yes your your argument to like
uh oh we won our division we're seven
and nine and now we're hosting some 11
and five football team
you're right i think that would whittle
it away you know
i guess the the big thing i would still
i i'm not mad at you there
i guess my resolution and the thing i
was gonna say is
like because i was gonna bring this up
in airing in grievance and you went this
way anyways
i i'd like to see like if there's a
two-game lead
by that other team right like if the
eagles win the nfc east
and they're seven and nine and there's
some other team that's nine and seven
like
it's a two game difference then they
should have to go on the road if it's a
one game difference i don't know i still
think there should be something said to
winning
the division you know what about those
years when the division's really awesome
and your record might not be as good
because you've had to play awesome teams
in your division
and some other teams got to play a bunch
of crappy people in their division and
everything like that
and now yeah okay we won the nfc west
let's take that let's just save that for
an example
but man we're the seahawks and we've
been beat up by the rams the 49ers the
cardinals are not that bad
and then some other team from another
division has a great record
that's where i would argue a little bit
that i don't necessarily
always agree that just because the
record's better
that means you should get the home field
advantage there has to be something for
winning the division at least the way
it's set up right now but i wish they
would have something in place
in case it got too crazy to go okay
we're going to change it this year
because you're so horrible you don't
deserve a home game
does that mean i don't like these yeah
it does and and i've made that argument
in the past that if there's enough of a
spread between the
nfc east champion and the 5c that the 5
seed gets the home game yeah right
i'm just saying let's avoid that
altogether if you go to three divisions
you're never going to have this problem
you're not going to have five teams
all of whom are horrible it's not going
to happen when you and i because i don't
remember it ever happening
back in the old days when when there
were five five and four
in in each division when there were 28
teams or when there were 30 teams so i i
don't i don't have a problem
with three divisions and then here's
what happens
you've got your three division winners
who earn home games in the playoffs
and your fourth seed the the best second
place team out of those three divisions
is definitely going to deserve a home
game in your five seed
well your four seed gets a home game and
then five six seven eight would be the
road teams if they ever do expand
to 16 playoff teams and i think they
will expand to 16 playoff teams at some
point and i think at some point chris
as gambling takes further route coast to
coast
legalized sports betting the first move
is increase the number of games
the next move is increase the number of
teams and i really do think there will
be a push for expansion
at some point as these teams become even
more valuable with legalized wagering
as there are more games as there is more
of a price to be paid to have a team i
think that
that expansion is going to become
inevitable and maybe you go from 32 to
34
and then to 36 and hopefully i live long
enough for that to happen i hope it
never happens i hate that i think it's
horrible well
i i think i think that that it very well
could
teams that are falling apart now and can
barely field rosters what are you gonna
do with four more teams
like 17 17 games with
with 36 teams that's a hell of a lot of
money and betting opportunities and that
sports i'm telling you the sports
betting is going to drive the nfl to
find ways to grow
and and and look at how the players are
resisting playing more games fine you
don't want to play more games
we'll just have more teams that's how we
get more games
the more teams you have the more games
are played the more jobs are available
every year the major colleges are
cranking out
far more players than there are jobs and
with
quarterbacks the key is quarterbacks
they don't care if defenses are bad they
want defenses to be bad
if there's enough quarterbacks and not
that long ago there weren't enough
but what have we seen in recent years as
coaches embrace
doing with quarterbacks what they did at
the college level all of a sudden these
guys are good
all of a sudden these teams are figuring
it out all of a sudden there's enough
quarterbacks to go around
to have 36 of them if they want to go
that direction and once they get a taste
of that gambling money
that's where it's going hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports